salut on est stagiaire au
multiplateforme à radio canada on est
ici dans le centre de l'information
on va demander aux fenêtres ce qu'il
prépare comme dans un secret si avec
gérald fillion gerald c'est quoi ton
péché mignon des pets de sauveur des
grands pères dans le sirop et du sirop
d'érable bien sûr je vois quand j'en
vois cette vidéo l'abandon j'ai dit on
arrête de manger toute faite parce que
tout ce que j'aime manger dans la ville
basse et la danse mon péché mignon c'est
le chocolat puis la bonne nouvelle c'est
que je partage ce régime avec mes
collègues parce qu'on fait souvent des
dégustations vers 3 4 heures du matin
péché mignon livre secret j'ai ces mêmes
problèmes que ça se limite à un élément
le sirop d'érable